la chronique de l'environnement comme
tous les mardis dans le 7-8 bonsoir
julie ce soir nous parlons botanique la
nature s'est invité sur le plateau avec
votre invité tout à fait donc nous
allons parler botanique avec christelle
bonal vous êtes botaniste indépendante
depuis un an seulement après une
carrière de juriste quelle reconversion
comment vous êtes tombés dans les
plantes mais en fait quand j'allais en
vacances avec mes parents en haute
savoie j'ai découvert la montagne lors
des randonnées avec avec mes parents et
les plantes et c'est là qu'est née ma
passion pour pour les plantes et la
botanique est donc très jeune vous avez
justement fait des études après à 30 ans
et ça dans le milieu oui voilà j'ai
suivi de formation successives à l'école
du paysage de versailles à l'école
d'architecturé toutes deux dans la
thématique des jardins et du paysage et
vous avez créé donc les petites herbes
qui est une auto entreprise vous vous
baladez justement dans ce cadre là dans
la nature et à titre personnel vous nous
avez ramené un échantillon de quelques
espèces printanières oui voilà je fais
les gens n'ont pas encore vu
enfin mon petit marché cet après midi
elles sont fraîches de cet après-midi de
500 domaine de saint cloud alors
justement va commencer avec les vertus
médicinales et culinaires de la première
par exemple l'ail des ours alors là il
des sources
qui est ici
avec lequel donc on fait de délicieux
pesto pour les pâtes donc on agrémente
avec de l'huile d'olive des pignons de
pin n'a pas forcément bien vu je vais
vous laisser les ouïes les montrer donc
en fait la feuille est tout jeune c'est
la meilleure époque pour la ramasser
pour faire pour en faire parce que ça
centre à des postes au
centre est bon si vous le sentiez se
font en effet ce sont très très fort
l'aïe et c'est justement ce qui permet
de distinguer deux
d'une plante qui pousse en même temps
que lui en ce moment le guen qui
celui-ci est toxique et ne sont pas là y
donc ça permet de
petite précision je cite donc je viens
on va en profiter faut pas accueillir
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi vous
présentait ce soir quelques échantillons
vous avez ramassé n'allait pas faire la
même chose c'est bien de travailler avec
les conseils d'un spécialiste voilà et
peut-être se promener aussi avec une
flore c'est un livre qui répertorie
toutes les plantes qui permet de les
identifier
en cas de doute les pharmaciens peuvent
répondre oui d'enfants des champions par
exemple autres voilà pharmaciens peuvent
toujours conseiller a bien donné
quelques précisions et quelle que soit
mon plein d'appels demain soir pour me
dire qu'il est j'ai surtout ce malade
tousse intoxiquée mais aussi nous avons
donc le plantain c'est ça pour qui la
musique intrigante voilà qui cas une
action voilà tout à fait cicatrisante en
cas de plaie de brûlures donc on se
frotte la main avec avec on voit lors on
peut en faire aussi des cataplasmes donc
ils sont des sortes de pansements de
pommade voilà de pommade
voilà comme des pommades on utilise de
la farine de liens de l'un pour pour
lier le
tout cas d'accord et on peut les manger
sous forme de come des pousses
d'épinards en fait oui voilà bah comme
comme l'ortie comme comme les lames y
ait en fait ça agrément que les salades
donc les feuilles peuvent être mangées
crues ou cuites mais on est souple et
gratin des farces et vous pourriez faire
koh lanta sans fils
vous avez déjà pensé me fera participer
parce que c'est mon petit secret il faut
vraiment être utile sauf que l'on fait
on est sûr de la flore locale et koh
lanta qu'on ne trouve tout ce que vous
nous avez un oui lorsqu'on trouve
vraiment dans la région parisienne oui
dans tous les espaces verts non
dépôt désherber enfin en tout cas là
c'était à saint cloud la rance des bois
donc qui a de nombreuses vertus
oui alors tout à fait donc la ronce qui
est ici donc en ce moment on peut pas
trop encore manger les feuilles faudra
attendre le mois d'avril pour manger les
jeunes les jeunes pousses mais sinon
donc en infusion pour
pour lutter contre la toux enfin pour
les allées les inflammations de la gorge
une plante très intéressante bon sans
oublier les ronds les fruits les murs
voilà les murs mais rousseau - oui voilà
donc c'est beaucoup plus tard mais clash
que vous amenez que la clé faye wallach
les feuilles le pissenlit qu'on connaît
aussi oui les fleurs on reconnaître ou
tout à fait bon là lâche t il passer
dessus donc je les olé pour l'aspect un
peu défraîchi donc le pissenlit qui à un
diurétique qui peut aussi ce donc se
manger en salade et le latex donc quand
on coupe la tige de la fleur ya latex
blanc qui en sort de la sève c'est ça
voilà bah c'est là c'est bon de m et
donc on peut l'appliquer pour pour
lutter contre les verrues d'accord et en
eau poursuit sur la grande orties tout à
fait et elle à celle idoine pour les
verrues voilà là bas sont les verrues
donc on peut aussi utiliser de lâcher
idoine cette fois ci la plante est
toxique on ne peut pas la manger et
contient des alcaloïdes toxiques pour le
foie les reins et elle son latex et
orange donc quand on est si vous en
trouvez une fraîche bon aussi ouais
enfin là bas ça ça va sortir
progressivement voilà le latex orange
dit étape qui doit être appliqué
directement sur sur la verrue mais
simplement le vise directement ben oui
directement celles qui se consomme
pareils qu'on peut qu'on peut manger
fois juste et l'avait voilà les laver et
c'est intéressant de les laver
surtout pour leurs tics hyper c'est son
aspect picon mais voilà c'est bien
manger c'est l'offre et la pluie soit la
pluie ou alors quand ouhlala reims perd
voilà ses poils ne sont plus requis donc
on disait tout à l'heure qu'il fallait à
prendre quelques précautions avoir des
connaissances un clip se tourner
éventuellement vers un pharmacien et
quels sont les contre-indications s'il y
en a pour les échantillons que vous avez
apporté alors pour ceux ci donc ne pas
manger la lâcher les douanes qui est une
plante toxique sinon des contre
indications pour des gens qui seraient
photosensible par les à dire par exemple
avait la grande berce berceau commune
produit des molécules
qui sont photosensible c'est à dire les
rayons du soleil les active et ça une
fois qu'on l'a 1 géré ça crie ça peut
nous créer des brûlures d'accord comme
celui ci aurait photosensible
la cij un médecin qui peut détruits et
sailly quand on voit là quand on subit
la chose une fois c'est l'appareil le
millepertuis aussi est une plante à
éviter quand on est photosensible en
tout cas faut pas s'exposer au soleil
après d'accord donc je rappelle on peut
voir un pharmacien ou mamie de vous
envoyer un mail spécialement avec une
photo de la plante entière enfin avec
quand même la feuille en entier ou la
plante entière ou la fleur éléments
d'identification de l'appelant et sinon
vous proposez donc des sorties
botaniques qui reprendront bientôt pour
découvrir la flore son image en ile de
france
quel est le concept enfin qu'est ce que
vous apprenez aux personnes et où se
déroulera la prochaine alors la
prochaine sortie se déroulera le 7 avril
au domaine national de saint cloud et
bien en fait ce que j'apporte aux gens
en fait je m'adapte au public soit j'ai
des gens qui connaissent bien la
botanique et je vais je vais encore plus
loin avec eux ou alors qui débute dans
la botanique et je leur apprend à
distinguer les différentes familles de
fleurs grâce à leurs caractères
morphologiques
ensuite pour ceux qui veulent en savoir
plus il faut il demande les noms latins
monde je m'adapte sedo des spécialistes
parlent à des spécialistes ou des gens
qui sont intéressés par les vertus
culinaires et médicinales donc j'adapte
mon discours en fait au public d'accord
et aussi le 26 mai vous proposerez sur
le thème du moyen-âge c'est ça voilà les
plantes cultivées au moyen âge donc
c'est les plantes cultivées les plantes
sauvages en fait c'est une double
thématique et donc ça sera fait en
partenariat avec la maison de
l'environnement de saint quentin en
yvelines et on se promènera dans le bois
d'aigrefins à saint rémy les chevreuse
on s'est retrouvé sa fiche d'être fin
oui ça c'est du côté de manier des
amours
et pour ceux qui ne trouveraient pas ses
plans du qui n'aurait pas envie de se
salir les bottes est-ce qu'on peut
acheter ces plantes les trouver ensuite
titre que bones étage il voit là bas
chez le pharmacien sous forme de gélules
très bien et bien je vous remercie
beaucoup christelle bonal d'être venu
partager votre passion avec nous sur le
plateau car c'est beaucoup de choses ce
soir grâce à vous merci on passe à
l'agenda présent julie tout à fait alors
une seule date à retenir cette semaine
la maison de l'environnement de magny
les hameaux justement qui propose un
atelier intitulé habitat pardon
construite on habite à spectaculaire
avec des capes là demain mercredi 6 mars
dès 14 heures animé par le centre cap là
pour permettre aux petits dès 3 ans de
réaliser des sculptures et architectures
éphémères à partir des fameuses petites
planchettes de bois voit laquelle on
aperçoit sur cette photo pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas les capelains les
enfants connaissent pas forcément très
bien merci encore à vous merci sur ce
point environnement dans le 7 8 l
édition de ce 5 mars qui se poursuit
avec une large page consacrée au salon
de l'automobile de genève et cette
implication des yvelines jusqu'en suisse
est resté avec nous le temps d'évoquer
cet autre dossier à d'actualité le vote
des étrangers aux scrutins locaux le
gouvernement va-t-il prendre sa décision
avant les municipales de 2014 l'enjeu
est de taille qu'en pensent les
principaux concernés promesses
historique de la gauche élargir le droit
de vote aux étrangers pour les élections
locales était la proposition numéro 82
françois mitterrand reprise par françois
hollande cette promesse présidentielle
devrait se concrétiser en 2014 une loi
constitutionnelle a déjà été adoptée en
première lecture au sénat en décembre
2011 mais le texte est depuis en attente
à l'assemblée nationale à partir du
moment où ils vivent vivement depuis
assez longtemps sur le territoire
français ils ont droit de voter ceux ci
sont quand même représentatif d'une
grande majorité je dirais de personnes
dans l'est des lieux de vos communautés
donc ils ont quand même le droit et un
mot à dire on paye notre impôt le loyer
ont subi la loi français pourquoi pas
admea les élections municipales
même pour la
cl vous pour élire un président de la
république dans un pays il faut être de
nationalité de cette de ce pays malgré
que moi je suis d'origine étrangère ça
je le soutiens et je leur fais j'en suis
d'accord mais tout ce qui au niveau
communal au niveau municipal régional et
où je pense que les habitants des
quartiers les habitants de la
municipalité de la région ils sont plus
à même de délire la solution pourrait
être le concept de réciprocité nous au
maroc les étrangers par exemple les
français expatriés qui sont installées
au maroc principalement marqué c'est son
droit de vote une idée partagée par le
maire de montigny le bretonneux il faut
aussi tenir compte de l'opinion des
français et ne pas les diviser sur des
sujets qui ne les intéressent pas mais
il peut y avoir d'autres d'autres
solutions aussi on peut y aller de
manière progressive tout simplement dans
la réciprocité ça serait pas mal déjà
que les français qui sont qui vivent
dans un pays étranger puisse aussi voter
dans le pays étranger à l'heure actuelle
les lui ni mantin évoque la
naturalisation des étrangers afin
d'obtenir les droits liés par contre du
côté de guyancourt c'est une évidence
les étrangers devraient pouvoir voter
aux élections locales et même pouvoir
s'y présenter comme candidat
je pense que des personnes qui vivent
sur un territoire qui vivent dans une
commune depuis plusieurs années qu'ils
payent des impôts des personnes dont les
enfants partagent nos écoles des
personnes qui participent à la vie
locale ça serait quand même une
reconnaissance et ça serait une
intégration supplémentaires les députés
yvelinois jean philippe mallet évoque
les mêmes valeurs en faveur de l'égalité
c'est important que pour les élections
locales les étrangers puissent voter ils
travaillent y contribue à la richesse de
notre pays et donc il est important
qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent voter
c'est un problème de 2 de dignité la
gauche est déterminé à obtenir la
majorité nécessaire des trois cinquièmes
au congrès pour réformer la constitution
reste à convaincre une trentaine de
parlementaires